your fellow passengers on a commercial
flight are usually diverse group
representing all of society but that's
not necessarily true behind the cockpit
door the vast majority of pilots are
white and male
but lately there have been efforts to
diversify the skies including a program
in california that's helping young
people earn their wings
chris van cleave has the story
this is what 70 miles an hour feels like
10 year old
can barely see over the controls but
he's in his element we're in a thousand
feet over los angeles i like it when i
land and when i take off i kind of like
the flying part i'm not a big fan of the
landing yeah it's just the landings can
be a little rough but once you get the
hang of it you'll just land perfectly
with mom cheering him on and documenting
each flight from the ground
aiden is chasing his dream
of becoming an airline pilot he's been
practicing flying the friendly skies
since he was eight they say dress for
the job you want
and aiden did that from day one come see
me
after ground instruction two saturdays a
month aiden and about 40 other kids from
8 to 18 fill this hangar for a morning
ground school at fly compton penetrate
through that ceiling is going to be
difficult right a non-profit exposing
young people to aviation hoping their
dreams take flight are there students
that you see in your class that you
expect to see in an airline cockpit one
day yeah i would say about
40 to 50 percent of the kids i'll see
them in cockpit for sure alaska airlines
pilot and compton native ron norman is
one of the program's founders he sees
firsthand the need to bring more
diversity to flying you're mistaken for
a flight attendant
oh yeah
oh all the time and the funny thing
about that is it comes from everybody it
doesn't come just from white people it
comes from black people as well 93
percent of pilots in the u.s are white
only about 5 percent are women and women
of color are estimated to be less than 1
i got on a commercial flight to cuba
back in 2017
i looked in the cockpit and both of the
pilots were african-american
and instantly that ignited my motivation
to become a pilot foundation president
demetrius harris decided to become a
professional pilot at age 40. what was
it about that that made that such a
light bulb moment seeing someone that
looks like me
doing a certain thing
i think is very powerful so i feel like
if it did that for me i could only
imagine what it could do for a small
child after ground school
it's time to fly it's so beautiful in
the air like flying is so beautiful and
i love it eighteen-year-old alicia
arnold is studying aviation at san jose
state release the brakes she is on case
to be fly compton's first teen to earn a
pilot's license something she'll do
before she even has her driver's license
driving a car is kind of scary because
it's you and then like that guy and then
that dude over there but then in the
year it's just so freeing one of the
biggest barriers to becoming a pilot is
the tens of thousands it can cost to
learn this summer fly compton will mark
its second year by helping some of its
older students earn their pilot's
licenses at little or no cost we're just
here to
reach one kid if we can do more decision
on a kick
for norman it's a chance to pay back
those who mentored him by paying it
forward
is it weird being a role model i never
thought of myself as a role model that's
the first time i heard that
y'all
ready i'm just afraid i'm just uh
someone here here to help guide i've
always thought of it as
bearing a torch you just got in the way
and young aiden is following in close
formation if he can do it i can do it
soaring to new heights while sending the
message
the sky is their only limit
for cbs saturday morning i'm chris van
cleave in compton california good aiden
that was very good
maybe that's the key to being a role
model is not thinking of yourself as the
role model but just leading by example
and helping and showing yeah and kids
watch and then but look at aiden there
yeah pretty impressive huh seeing so
many of these flight schools or flight
training programs pop up all over the
country whether it was you know a carol
hobson through that story a
united airlines pilot or you know a
jerome stanislaus a guy who wanted to be
a professional pilot but just wasn't
able to get you know his wings
accessibility and it's not just the kids
as we saw there how about somebody
switching at 40 years old yeah
that was carol's story yeah that's
awesome